uh next one is would you rather know the
definitive answer to what happens after
we die or know exactly how long you have
left to live that's good question I
think I'd rather have the definitive
answer of what happens after we die I
don't want either that's this is yeah
but you have to Pi I have to pick one if
I had to pick I'd get the answer of what
happens after we die I think I'd
actually like to know how long I have
left to live really definely do not if
if presuming it cannot change yeah so
this is like a [__] Death Note thing
you could see the vision see you're
thinking about [__] I I I hear that
and it's just 90 years old I'm like
bring in the [__] be that's the thing
let's get going I'm going to live till
90 [__] see if if that was the case
with all of us then we would pick that
being like oh you have 57 years left to
live and you'll be like sweet but what
if it's like you eat a hamburger and the
[__] thing goes down to like 20 like
what if that hamburger change or it's
like or it's like uh you have 2 minutes
yeah like let me load up the memes right
now I got to watch this de me before I
die you watch you watch that one porn
category you're like I don't know if I
should watch this you watch it and you
immediately lose 10 you're like what
what does this lead to yeah what if what
if just like you do some like asinine
activity and it's just like why did my
life go down by 12 years yeah uh yeah
I'd like to that would that would kill
me I don't really care what happens to
us when we die even if it's good bad or
nothing I'm kind of indifferent towards
all of it I don't know I'm c i I want to
know just because a new game plus anyway
right we start and do some [__] so it
doesn't [__]
matter I don't know I just I would just
like to know because it's like if even
if it's either good or bad it's like I
can't avoid it yeah so I'm just like
well I'd rather that than like living
with the pressure of like oh [__] I've
only got how many years the best thing
ever and then you're like well [__] it
I'll die now why wait and no no no less
the worst if it's the worst thing ever
like hell right you'd be like [__] I I
don't want to die and you'd be so scared
of death and and then I'd be like all
right well then I'm going to try and
live for as long as possible yeah well
that's that's why that's why I don't
really want to know either answer but I
think the one that would affect me less
like what happens after we die let's
what's like the worst case scenario we
go to hell and we suffer for eternity
real life right sure um no it's not hell
huh it's not hell we haven't figured
that [__] out you think you think Bozo
figured it out and wrote it in a book
for us [__] no but okay what what do you
think is the worst possible thing
nothing that's the worst possible thing
infinite Darkness forever no no just
like you're gone that's it I think I
think people just don't want to accept
that we're just nothing when we're done
no that's I don't I don't think that's a
bad thing per se I I I [__] with it I
like the idea why should I be I would
rather stop existing than suffer like
consciously suffer for the rest of
Eternity I think that you know like I
think when we are we are all specs on
this universe and we all get our moment
and we enjoy it and we're done and like
why should your conscience have to carry
on why should you be being gets to carry
on cuz I'm the main character coner
that's what we all want to think but
we're just done like that's it you're
done afterwards like there's nothing
wrong with that like you know this
there's uh you won't even have the
ability to know you're gone cuz you're
You're gone although if I were to be
Devil's Advocate right like if say for
example after you die the answer is you
go to hell and you suffer for an
eternity let's say like let's say like
you know hypothetically speaking Yeah
hypothetically let's say like you know
[__] Satan puts you in a pool of
boiling hot water and you have to sit in
there for the rest of Eternity right you
have an eternity you're going to get
used to it yeah you'd get used to it so
fast you'd get used to it be like yeah I
guess like after like 5,000 years you'd
be like oh turn it up a it's a bit cold
you
know is this assuming you can't die yeah
well because it's an eternity right you
can't die you're already dead right so
you're basically going to be boiling for
the rest of your life you're going to
get used to it after a while but it's
not exactly a pleasant experience is it
it's not pleasant at first yeah that's
like what you mean that's that's like a
very biblical way of looking at hell I
think that like hell could also be just
being stuck in Ohio for like four years
that's true that's true maybe I mean
some people are living that maybe we're
in hell right now we're living amongst
people who are also serving their time
in hell yeah what if existence is
hell what if what if what if this is the
S think about that
atheist all right let's go next one all
right something a bit Tamer uh also from
Derrik Wells would you rather have an
unlimited entertainment budget but be
heavily restricted on your food budget
or have an unlimited food budget but be
restricted on your entertainment
entertainment is such a that's such a
broad word that that could cover so many
things Games movies food is my
entertainment as well it's true yeah
like oh [__] did you just play did you
just out play the game entertainment
entertainment could also in some aspects
could be like travel or yeah yeah you
know staying you know so I think if you
we talking about travel now well yeah
travel is entertainment for a lot of
people okay let me let me rephrase this
question a little bit would you [__] you
we're Chang your I guess if that is your
real name yeah uh would you rather eat
like a broke college student your entire
life but have all the games and travel
that you want you just describe my
life that's me right now you don't eat
like a broke college student yes I do
[__] off Joey comp to comp to you
[__] [__] to you [__] how often do
you go to like fancy restaur I [__]
cooks for you and you eat well what are
you talking
about that that is not a broke student
Joey before Aki and when AK is not here
I am [__] chomping on the worst [__]
imaginable what do you that what do you
like [__] like gudon every single day
BR gon's great what are you talking
about excuse you gon is the college food
in Japan are you kidding me I love that
visceral call out got you go to [__]
nice restaurants all the
time you do I barely go to restaurants
you go to you do go to the restaurants I
think the least out of all of us yeah
absolutely but you also cook at home or
you have someone cook you at home which
there is there is something really
really [__] nice about a homecooked
meal you know home I mean I'm not going
to say no to a nice restaurant obviously
but I'm not going to go out of my way to
go to one you know okay so what you're
saying is you would look this is not me
saying I never take Ary to nice
restaurant I
do you don't no but that's the great
thing a a is exactly the same as me in
the sense that she also doesn't care
about
restaurants just like you she comes home
from like a hard day works like honey
don't worry I'll cook for us yeah but
like brings out the [__] bring out
the Uber bring out the instant Ramen
it's just like okay honey you go babe
it's a special day you can choose
between Mata or
sukia options I like uber I like I like
yeah so like if I had to pick like I
would pick the first one the unlimited
entertainment budget cuz I love
traveling I love games I love movies all
that kind of stuff and food budget you
can in Japan especially you can still
eat pretty well with a restricted food
budget yeah uh you obviously struggle
when you're traveling of course but if
you don't include travel in the
entertainment budget hey I'm living yeah
worst comes the worst I will pick
unlimited entertainment over I mean food
to me is very much you mean I I enjoy a
good meal it's something I look forward
to every day but that isn't so much
dependent on how much of a budget you
have a lot of times just depending on
how much of an effort can you put into
learning how to cook something you like
and doing that uh more often than not
because you finding a good place on a
lower budget right ex obviously exists
exactly so it's a lot
easier uh pretty good for the limited
food budget really yeah I could have
some I just go out every single night to
a nice R
restaurant you get bored of it you get
tired of you get bored of it I haven't
so
far all right Mr listen I go every I
just I go out every night no I I I don't
think I do you never like crave a
home-cooked meal
no no bro really no I never there's just
something like warming and homely about
I I like it but I've never thought man I
really want one right now this man's
been in La too
much one this is this is what Uber eat
does to a [__] I love Uber Eats
it's so good this is what Uber does to a
[__] a restaurant meal in the
comfort of my home it's so
good all right restaurants yeah I love
love my to death but yeah like
restaurants are restaurants for a reason
no but okay there's something about a
homecooked meal that listen if it was
your mom's homecooked meal yeah maybe
there's a different equation here your
Mom it's just my do your parents are
your parents good Cooks yeah they're
okay that was the most real
answer that was like uh what can I say
without them dising me from my family
mean they they they they swear to me
they're very good now which I sure they
are um but I just yeah all right well
listen I had I had I had G's mom's home
cooking and I was like this pretty fire
though that is true it I think I think
the answer makes a big difference if you
have at least one parent who like bri
British this is a different question you
know what I mean I mean the the thing I
loved about homecooked meals is that
okay you have like restaurant quality
meals you can go to like a melin star
restaurant but sometimes there are
certain dishes that you like the way
that you like it and with homecooked
meals you can just make it to exact
to your taste profile exactly you know
sometimes you get a dish and like this
is 80% of how much I actually want of
this dish yeah uh but like you know
you're satisfied with it but you're like
damn I wanted just that little bit more
you know there's a few places you can do
that I got a few places I go where
they'll customize if I ask I think
that's how restaurants get you as well
right like cuz like you have that
feeling of like damn I wish there was a
little bit more and then that just
incentivizes you to go back to that
restaurant again what do you mean like
is it it don't you think it's kind of
seems like a bit of of a marketing
scheme to be like oh we're going to give
you just a little bit less than what you
actually want so that you have that
craving to have it again I mean I think
I just eat more than the average person
on a meal right cuz I it it takes a
little bit more for like to fill me up
than someone like Sydney who is uh a lot
smaller than me you know so it's you
know it just depends restaurant they
have to serve for the average person and
most of the times we eat more than the
average person above average yeah and
you know the way you uh you know the way
a lot of guys offset that is uh they get
a girlfriend or they get a wife and then
and then they eat just like 20% less and
they're like you're not going to finish
that honey yeah don't worry don't worry
say less say less I I'll do it for you
I'll do it for you all right you get two
meals for the price of one all right uh
what's the next
one would you rather gain a million
dollar but need to [__] out an entire
Year's worth of Po poop in a single day
or [__] one year worth of poop and never
have to [__] for the rest of that entire
year this is easy I would do the first
one gain a million dollars and [__] out
entire years worth of poop in a single
day why why there also apologies poop
topic but I want to see the Mone sh why
why well one of these I get to have a
million dollars and one of them I don't
dude it' be like dude if I made a Tik
Tok of that I'd make the [__] I'd
make an extra million although it would
be kind of useful never to need a [__]
again um I like [__] though I like I
kind of do like [__] though yeah
yeah it's yeah that's like saying you
know pee if it was peeing I think I
would like to not oh if it was peeing
it'd be a different peeing is actually
just a burden sometimes it is peeing
is the difference between peeing and
[__] yeah no one ever looks forward
to a p sometimes I look forward to I
never look forward to a p i always look
forward to my sh when I you know I have
a nice bit day I got I got a heated sea
I Got 5 10 minutes on to chill out it's
great I feel yeah I feel like most guys
would answer the first one because we
just love out [__] an entire Year's
worth of poop in a single day I don't
think it' take that long D you'd be like
Randy from that one episode in Family
Guy that's like how how long will that
take I did I say Family Guy I meant
South Park I don't think I have enough
hours in the day to put out all the [__]
and CU you you take an hour
yeah all right I think it would take
more than a single day for you to [__]
out done two hours You' done